I do not understand why people transfer  loyalty to role models you have to be  incredibly naive about what people are  to believe that a role model is in fact  worthy because you know people are just  people and there's no III don't see  great differences in spiritual elevation  among people  that's why lineages and all that seem to  me just another form of foolishness the  mushroom spoke to me once on this  subject many years ago and said for one  human being to seek enlightenment from  another is like one grain sand on the  beach to seek enlightenment from another  it's a wonderful statement about our  commonality if you want to talk to the  dalai lama close the door of your  bedroom and have a dialogue with the  mirror you're as good as the darling who  could suppose otherwise